[Musik]
was er soeben gesehen habt sind
möglicherweise Vorboten eines Frühlings
natürlich geht es nicht um die
Jahreszeit ich meine das im politischen
Sender die Rede ist von einem Protest
wie beim arabischen Frühling vor ein
paar Jahren als dieses Video gedreht
wurde hatten sich die Iraner bereits
seit Wochen erhoben um gegen das molare
Regime zu protestieren es handelt sich
dabei schon längst nicht mehr nur um
einen reinen Protest gegen eine
bestimmte Politik oder um irgendeine
Entscheidung der Regierung es geht nicht
mehr um Sachfragen es geht hier ums
Eingemachte die Protestler wollen das
Regime der Religionsführer ein für alle
Mal stürzen dafür gehen hunderttausende
seit Mitte September auf die Straßen und
Plätze dort treffen sie auch Polizei und
Militär und die schlagen erbarmungslos
zu der protestiert riskiert sein Leben
erleben wir also einen iranischen
Frühling wegen diese Protest am Ende die
radikalen Religionsführer hinweg nur es
wäre ein historisches Ereignis eine
eigenes das so wichtig ist wie der
Ausgang des Krieges in der Ukraine aber
so weit sind wir noch lange nicht alles
könnte auch einen sehr negativen Ausgang
haben und zwar für die gesamte Welt von
einem größeren Krieg im Mittleren Osten
also wollt ihr mehr darüber wissen was
ich im Iran zusammenbraut dann bleibt
jetzt dran
[Musik]
die Islamische Republik Iran ist mehr
als nur ein von radikalen regierter
Gottesstaat das Land hat Potenzial vor
allem wirtschaftlich rund 94 Millionen
Menschen leben dort und was die Gas und
Ölvorkommen angeht kann das Land ist mit
jeder Monarchie am Golf aufnehmen mit
den iranischen Ressourcen auf dem
internationalen Markt wäre derzeitige
Energiekrise kein so großes Problem mehr
aber iranische Rohstoffe gibt es
praktisch nicht mehr international zu
kaufen wegen der wirtschaftsaktion und
die haben ihre Gründe denn wie ihr
sicher wisst suchte Iran seit
Jahrzehnten eine eigene Atombombe zu
entwickeln das jedoch ist ein immenses
Sicherheitsproblem in das regime-betrug
seit Jahrzehnten seine Nachbarn in der
Region nicht nur Israel sondern
praktisch alle anderen islamischen
Länder dort und mit dem Westen ist das
Jeans sowieso Spinne Feind kurzum kein
vernünftiges Land möchte radikaler
Islamisten sehen über fortgeschrittene
Militärtechnik verfügen deshalb die
Sanktionen die es den Regime schwer
machen an Hightech zu kommen wenn aber
auch teste wirklich Kraft hätten die
schiitischen Religionsführer zu stürzen
könnten wir dann einen demokratischen
Iran erleben mit all den Vorteilen die
Demokratisierung üblicherweise mit sich
bringt also Frieden Menschenrechte
bessere Chancen auf Wohlstand und so
weiter
[Musik]
nun das kann niemand voraussehen und
ehrlich gesagt klingt das zu schön um
wahr zu sein skepsis ist angebracht denn
es ist nicht das erste Mal dass die
Iraner auf die Straße gehen schon 2009
gab es Proteste gegen manipulierte
Wahlen und dann im Jahr 2019 wegen der
miesen wirtschaftlichen Lage aber eine
Veränderung zum Besseren haben wir im
Iran nicht gesehen ganz im Gegenteil das
regime-zug steht die Fesseln noch weiter
an auch die Führer des Landes werden
radikale in den letzten zehn Jahren war
der Präsident des Iran dieser Herr den
ihr jetzt auf den Bildschirm seht hast
deine rohani ein Präsident des
gemäßigten Flügel des Regimes doch seit
2021 hat er Iran diesen anderen Herrn
als Präsidenten die Rede ist von
Ibrahima easy der den hardcoreflügel des
theokratischen Regimes angehört mit
anderen Worten es sind harte Zeiten für
das iranische Volk die Sanktion gegen
das Land schlagen voll durch mit allem
was dazugehört Krise Inflation
Arbeitslosigkeit und die Staatsführung
wird immer repressiver sie mischt sich
in banalste Dinge des Alltags ein wie
zum Beispiel die Kleidung die jeder
Anlage trägt
[Musik]
tja was Menschen tragen und auch wie Sie
es tragen davon sind die religiösen
Führer des Iran wirklich besessen für
aia toller Kammern müssen sich alle so
kleiden wie es seiner Auslegung des
islamen spricht und das betrifft vor
allem die Frauen der hitchart gibt
Frauen Freiheit und Identität trotz der
sinnlosen und oberflächlichen
Propaganda-Kampagne die von
materialistischen Menschen notiert
werden fesselt der hitchup die Frauen
dicht ah ja toller common ey kann man es
Besessenheit ging so weit dass er 2005
die Gast hat die Sittenpolizei ins Leben
rief wir reden hier von einer Polizei
die haben einzige Aufgabe darin besteht
auf den Straßen zu kontrollieren und
dafür zu sorgen dass niemand
unmoralische Dinge tut und unmoralische
Dinge bedeuten vor allem sich nicht
vorschriftsmäßig zu kleiden die euch
vorstellen könnt betrifft das vor allem
Frauen sie sind nicht nur verpflichtet
den headschaft zu tragen also ein
Kopftuch oder ein Schleier sie müssen
ihn auch richtig tragen und man sollte
seitens des Staates auch keine noch so
irrsinnigen Aufwände das richtige tragen
zu verordnen hier ein Beispiel im August
22 veröffentlichte das Amt für die
Förderung der Tugend und die Verhütung
des Lasters ein 119 seitiges Dokument in
dem steht wie sich eine Frau kleiden
sollte
denn auch wenn eine Frau eine hip-up
trägt kann die Sittenpolizei sie mit der
Begründung verhaften dass Sie das
Kleidungsstück falsch trägt oder das
daran irgendwas nicht stimmt und
normalerweise wird sie dann auf eine
Wache der Sittenpolizei geschleppt um
sich dort einem unerziehungskurs zu
unterziehen danach muss ein
Familienmitglied sie abholen und er
angemessene Kleidung bringen damit sie
wieder auf die Straße gehen kann wenn
sie jedoch wieder straffällig wird das
heißt mit falscher Kleidung erwischt
drohen Geldstrafen oder gefängnisschläge
oder auch alles zusammen Willkür ist im
Staate Iran ein ständiger Begleiter der
moralpolizei wobei ist männlichen
Sittenwächtern eigentlich offiziell
nicht erlaubt ist Frauen zu Felsen
deshalb bestehen die Patrouillen in der
Regel aus zwei Männern und zwei Frauen
ja so verrückt ist für westliche Ohren
klingen mag die iranische moralpolizei
hat quasi genderquoten
[Musik]
unter dem neuen ultra konservativen
präsenten Ibrahim Reich easy
patroullieren seit 2021 immer mehr
Moralwächter auf den Straßen zu den
erleichterten moderne Techniken von
Überwachungskamera deren Arbeit vor
allem in den Städten umso mehr haben
will und Folter zugenommen es fehlte
also nur noch eine eigenes dass das fast
überlaufen ist
[Musik]
und im September 2022 war es dann soweit
als diese Nachricht um die Welt geht
Master armini die bei der iranischen
Sittenpolizei ins Koma viel stirbt im
Krankenhaus Masa Amini war ein junges
kurdisches Mädchen das von der
Sittenpolizei brutal zusammengeschlagen
wurde und anschließend verstarbt das
Regime rechtfertigte den Todesfall damit
dass das Mädchen gesundheitliche
Probleme gehabt habe aber iranische
Aktivisten haben später Aufnahmen ihrer
Verletzungen erhalten und konnten die
Version der Polizei widerlegen diese
Nachricht hat die meisten Iraner schwer
geschockt und so wurden die größten
Proteste der jüngsten Geschichte des
Landes ausgelöst es hatte sich
ordentlich was angestaute die Iraner
haben in Wirklichkeit noch viel mehr
Gründe zu protestieren und diese werden
wir uns jetzt genauer ansehen
der Kuchen ist kleiner aber weniger
Leute essen davon
der Iran ist eines der am stärksten
isolierten Länder der Welt seit dem
Sturz des Charles 1979 und der
sogenannten islamischen Revolution
leitet das Land und das Sanktionen denn
die USA nahmen damals den neuen
Machthabern die Geiselnahme in der
US-Botschaften mehr als Übel ab 2006
hagelte es dann seitens der UN
Sanktionen wegen des iranischen
Atomprogramms auch die EU-Beschluss 2012
Sanktionen gegen Teheran 2015 wurden
diese dann gelockert man hatte den
sogenannten Iran atomdeal geschlossen
doch schon 2018 erklärte US-Präsident
Trump den Ausstieg der USA aus diesem
Abkommen und verhängte ein neues
sanktions Regime dieses umfasste auch
sekundär Sanktion das heißt
Strafmaßnahmen gegen Länder welche die
primärsaktionen umgehen es ist also
überhaupt nicht einfach wenn ich da
hochgradig riskant mit diesem Land
Geschäfte zu machen nicht einmal mit den
Produkten der riesigen iranischen Öl-
und Gasfelder aber wie kann ein Land
solche Sanktionen verkraften nun wir
könnten es in einem Satz zusammenfassen
der Kuchen ist kleiner geworden aber
dafür essen weniger davon okay aber was
ist damit gemeint lasst es mich erklären
überraschenderweise war eine der ersten
Auswirkungen der Sanktionen gegen den
Iran der Anstieg des dortigen
Aktienmarktes die Teheraner Börse war
2019 die Börse die weltweit am meisten
zugelegt hat ganz schön komisch nicht
wahr der Grund dafür ist aber schon
nicht mehr so schön für die Menschen im
Iran denn seitdem die Iraner gilt nicht
mehr aus der Landes bringen können
können sie nur noch in einheimische
Unternehmen investieren und da die
Landeswährung der Real in den letzten
Jahren dramatisch an Wert verliert wird
der Aktienmarkt als eine Art sicherer
Hafen angesehen das heißt Aktiendepot
schlägt Sparbuch außerdem haben die
klerikalen Machthaber des Iran die
Bürger auch noch dazu ermutigt Aktien zu
kaufen was die Nachfrage nach
Wertpapiere natürlich ankurbelte
das heißt die Iraner sind zur
Aktienanlage gezwungen mangels
Alternativen und weil es der Staat zu
wünschen tja das klingt gar nicht gut
aber es wird noch schlechter
[Musik]
mit der Iran kann ja kaum waren ins
Ausland exportieren außer vielleicht
jene an Russland gelieferten kampfdrohen
mit den Putin jetzt ukrainische Städte
terrorisiert solch ein Exportverbot ist
an sich schon eine sehr schlechte
Nachricht für alle iranischen
Unternehmen aber es hat noch einen
weiteren Effekt denn wenn praktisch
niemand auf der Welt iranische Warenkauf
muss auch niemand mehr iranische real
kaufen um diese waren zu bezahlen
[Musik]
das bedeutet dass die Nachfrage nach
real als stark gesunken ist alleine im
Jahr 2018 nach der Ankündigung von Trump
Sanktionen während die Währung auf den
offiziellen Markt und mehr als 60% und
auf den freien Markt um mehr als 80%
[Musik]
. und die direkte Folge davon eine
galoppierende Inflation diese macht den
Menschen im Rahmen den Alltag ziemlich
schwer um euch eine Vorstellung davon zu
geben es gibt viele grundlegende
Produkte wie etwa eine Tube Zahnpasta
deren Preis sich jeden Tag ändert und
die Menschen versuchen verzweifelt ihre
billigwährung inhaltet diesen wie etwa
dem Dollar zu tauschen aber wie reagiert
die Regierung auf diese Zustände nun
ehrlich wie Argentinien wozu wir schon
einmal ein Video gemacht haben dass ich
euch verlinke die Regierung erschafft
einfach einen offiziellen Wechselkurs
der wenig oder gar nichts mit dem
Marktpreis zu tun hat wobei dann die
Unternehmen die mit der Regierung eng
verbunden sind Dollars zu eine
vorteilhafteren Wechselkurs erwerben
können der Rest der Untertanen kann pro
Kopf nur bis zu 2000 $ oder Euro pro
Jahr kaufen
aber natürlich finden die einfachen
Iraner irgendwie Wege an Dollar zu
kommen auch wenn es umständlich oder
illegal ist Schwarzmarkt und Schmuggel
blühen in diesem Land besonders in
Städten die an den Grenzen zu anderen
Ländern liegen
und während all dies geschieht werden
die Menschen Emirate gängend und
gefoltert werden während sie krumme
Geschäfte machen müssen um über die
Runden zu kommen währenddessen leben die
Eliten die mit den Mulas eng verbunden
sind in Saus und Braus die Eliten haben
die absolute Kontrolle über den Iran
erlangt letztlich haben die Sanktionen
dieser kleinen Gruppe also eher noch
geholfen aber unter all diesen
Nutznießern gibt es eine Institution die
es besonders gut hat die islamische
Revolutionsgarde im Iran existieren zwei
parallele Armeen auf der einen Seite die
reguläre Armee und auf der anderen die
islamische Revolutionsgarde
[Musik]
aber wie ist es möglich dass er Iran
zwei verschiedene Armeen hat nun darüber
haben wir schon mal ein eigenes Video
gedreht dass ich euch verlinken werde
hier kommt aber noch mal die
Zusammenfassung um alles zu verstehen
gehen wir bis ins Jahr 1979 zurück als
eiertoller Comedy den Schafen Persien
und die Machtübernahme trautete
iranischen Armee nicht weil sie dem
Schar gegenüber loyal war also schuf er
eine Art patrojanergarde deren Aufgabe
es war die Werte der islamischen
Revolution zu verteidigen aber täuscht
euch nicht diese Karte besteht nicht nur
aus ein paar Soldaten die ihren Führer
beschützen wir sprechen hier von einer
vollwertigen Armee mit mehr als 50.000
Soldaten eine gut bewaffneten und gut
ausgebildeten Elitetruppe und deren
Unterhalt kostet viel viel Geld schaut
euch mal diese Grafik an
[Musik]
wie ihr sehen könnt wächst das Budget
der islamischen revolutionskarte ja für
Jahr mit anderen Worten das einfache
iranische Volk wird immer
ärmer und ärmer aber das seinen mächtige
Garde
und das ist noch nicht alles
[Musik]
die islamische Revolutionsgarde
finanziert sich nicht nur aus den
Steuern der leichtgeprüften gerade sie
hat auch ihre eigenen Konzern und
Unternehmensstrukturen sie ist quasi ein
Staat im Staate es wird geschätzt dass
80% der gesamten iranischen Wirtschaft
in den Händen der islamischen
Revolutionsgarde liegen natürlich gehört
Ihnen auch ein Großteil des iranischen
Öls und Gases die kontrolliert die
wichtigsten Gasfelder im Süden des
Landes aber wir reden hier nicht nur
über natürliche Ressourcen die
revolutionsgarten sind zum Beispiel der
Hauptaktionär der beiden größten
Telekommunikationsunternehmen des Landes
ähnlich sieht es im Baugewerbe aus das
führende Bauunternehmen des Irans gehört
dieser Truppe über staatliche
Bauprojekte gibt's da auch immer was zu
verdienen im September 2020 hat sie 285
aktive Bauprojekte am Laufen dieses Jahr
gibt der Staat ihnen zum Beispiel 100
Millionen Dollar um die Moscheen des
Landes zu renovieren tja da sieht man
wohin das Geld fließt
fassen wir also kurz zusammen die
wirtschaftlichen Verhältnisse im Iran
haben zwei Auswirkungen erstens
weiterbreitete Armut und zweitens enorme
Ungleichheit zusammen mit den täglichen
Repressalien eine moralpolizei ist das
der perfekte Cocktail und soziale
Unruhen auszulösen und eben weil es so
sehr geehrt in einem Land mit derartigen
Zuständen ist es kein Wunder dass dann
eine Ereignis wieder Tod von Masa armini
etwas ins Rollen brachte zumal man sich
noch eine Sache klar machen muss zu
religiös radikal sich das Regime mit
seinem moralpolizei auch gibt es hat
dies bitter nötig denn das Volk tickt
zum größten Teil ganz anders und
erklären euch was wir damit meinen
[Musik]
viel mehr als Proteste
anders als in der versaute Arabien gibt
es in Iran eine große säkular geprägte
Bevölkerung die gar nicht in einem
Gottesstaat also eine Theokratie leben
möchte als Comedy zum Beispiel vor über
40 Jahren die Macht an sich riss
brauchte er die Hilfe säkularer Gruppen
darunter auch der Kommunistischen Partei
sie war ihm ein nützlicher Helfer vor
allem wenn es gegen westliche Einflüsse
gehen dann aber hat es komeni innerhalb
weniger Jahre geschafft diese Gruppen
der einstigen Helfer seiner Revolution
zu neutralisieren aber von dieser fast
schon pluralistischen Gesellschaft ist
bis heute etwas geblieben die einfachen
Menschen im Iran haben eine relativ
hohes Bildungsniveau und sind nicht so
radikalisiert wie in anderen
muslimischen Ländern das erklärt warum
es im Iran in der Vergangenheit so viele
Protestwellen gab die auch Demokratie
einforderten in den 1990er Jahren gab es
zum Beispiel mehrere Studentenproteste
im Jahr 2009 demonstrierten viel Iraner
gegen Wahlbetrug 2019 forderten die
Menschen wirtschaftliche Reformen aber
keiner dieser Proteste forderte einen
wirklich totalen Regimewechsel die
Slogans die jetzt auf den Straßen des
Iran skandiert werden sind aber ganz
anders schaut sie euch an Demonstranten
in Teheran skandieren Tod dem Diktator
während sich die Proteste ausweiten die
Proteste haben sich über das ganze Land
ausgebreitet von der Hauptstadt heran
bis hin zu den kleinen Städten auf dem
Land
natürlich hat die iranische Polizei mit
äußerstem Brutalität geantwortet
Aktivisten gehen von 15.000
Festgenommenen aus von denen mindestens
1.000 bereits angeklagt wurden hartliner
in iranischen Parlament fordern harte
Urteile bis hin zu Todesstrafen für sie
doch anders als bei früheren Protesten
schlagen die Protestierenden jetzt zur
Iran geht an das Fünfer besten darunter
zwei oberste nach Zusammenstößen im
Südosten getötet wurden bei dieser
Meldung handelt es sich um das Massaker
von Sache dann Ende September diesen
Jahres es wurden dort nicht nur
Revolutionswächter getötet sondern auch
96 Demonstranten Sache dann ist eine
Stadt die an der Grenze zu Afghanistan
und Pakistan liegt
und diese Lage hat durchaus eine
Bedeutung wie vorher bereits beschrieben
ist wegen der Sanktionen der Schmuggel
einer der wichtigsten Wirtschaftszweige
im Iran deswegen kommt den Regionen in
Grenznähe besondere Bedeutung zu im
Dreiländereck Iran Pakistan und
Afghanistan ist es sehr einfach
angeschmuggelte Waffen zu kommen das
nutzt natürlich auch die Protestler aus
und sie konnten sich bewaffnen das ging
so weit dass kreiskräfte dort eine
Zeitlang überfordert waren und die
Proteste nicht unterdrücken konnten bis
Verstärkung einrückte was dann im
Blutbad endete nachdem was von Leuten
hören die sich im Iran befinden ist
Teheran relativ gut unter der Kontrolle
des Regimes aber in den Grenzen andere
Regionen wird es immer komplizierter von
dort damit auch Bilder von Mädchen die
vor den Augen der Polizei ihren ablegten
oder Bilder von kamen verbrannten ist
das vielleicht die Chance für den besten
demokratische Bestrebungen zu
unterstützen kann der Westen helfen die
Molas zerstören nun viel scheint an
dieser Front nicht zu passieren aber es
gibt teilweise Forderungen nach mehr
Sanktionen gegen die Eliten des Iran und
deren Kinder die oft im Westen leben im
Prinzip so wie bei den russischen
Oligarchen aber wäre es möglich die
Demonstranten zu bewaffnen und das wäre
sehr riskant denn vergesst nicht das
Regime verfügt nicht nur über
Polizeikräfte sondern auch die
revolutionsgarten die sehr gut
ausgebildet sind deren Ausbildung ist
eben genau auf den städtischen geringer
Krieg und die Aufstandsbekämpfung
spezialisiert und diese Truppen können
schon eine Zeit lang im Kampf
durchhalten hier könnte also ein
langwieriger Bürgerkrieg drohen fakt ist
es geht gewaltig im Land das iranische
Regime stand noch nie so sehr unter
Druck wie jetzt nicht einmal
Massenverhaftung oder die Tötung von
Zivilisten konnten die Proteste
niederschlagen zudem ist die Lage auch
außenpolitisch sehr schwierig für das
Regime
der einzige große Verbündete der Teheran
noch bleibt ist Russland das aber wegen
seines katastrophal verlaufenden Ukraine
kriegst kommt beistandleisten kann falls
im Iran die Lage eskaliert vielmehr ist
es ja gerade genau umgekehrt Iran hilft
Russland mit Drohnen und vielleicht auch
bald mit Raketen um sie auf die Ukraine
abzufeuern
Iran liefert Drohnen an Russland Allianz
der Paria starten die neue militärisch
Zusammenarbeit zementiert ein neues
Bündnis bald könnten raketenlieferungen
folgen wobei der Iran diese Waffen
eventuell in Kürze selbst gut gebrauchen
könnte wenn sich die jüngsten gehandies
Berichte über Wahrheiten sollten dass er
eine militärischen Angriff auf
Saudi-Arabien vorbereitet ja ihr habt
richtig gehört schaut
die Arabien und USA ein hoher
Alarmbereitschaft nach Warnung vor
bestehenden iranischen angreifen die
Saudis waren nämlich dass die Mullah
Herrscher die letzte Chance für ihre
Jean darin sehen die Proteste mit einer
nationalen religiösen aufwandlung und
einer mobilenmachung gegen einen äußeren
Feind zu ersticken wenn es dazu kommen
sollte hätte das in der Tat globale
Auswirkungen stellt euch einmal vor wie
sich ein beträgt quer über den
Persischen Golf und die dortigen Öl und
Gas in die Rate auf die weltweite
Energieversorgung auswirken würde und
während das nicht vielleicht sogar wie
einzelne Vietnam oder Korea an
klassischer Stellvertreterkrieg zwischen
Russland und den USA wobei einige ja
momentan eher Russland als den Proxy
Irans im Krieg gegen die USA ansehen gut
jetzt haben wir vielleicht den Bogen
etwas zu weit gespannt vom Tod einer
jungen Frau in den Händen ihrer Peiniger
bis zu einem möglichen größeren Krieg im
Mittleren Osten denn so weit muss es ja
nicht kommen auf jeden Fall tut sich
etwas im Iran und die möglichen Folgen
dieser Entwicklung haben wir jetzt
Umrissen das Regime kann noch mal davon
kommen auch wenn die Proteste schärfer
sind als jemals zuvor die Modas könnten
stürzen was wohl das beste Szenario für
die Welt wäre das Iran könnte aber auch
explodieren wie die vorherige Nachricht
gezeigt hat es kann also gut sein dass
die Metapher Frühling doch wieder nur
Hoffnung ausdrückt aber am Ende
Enttäuschung bleibt wie eben damals beim
arabischen Frühling deine herbe
Enttäuschung für alle war die sich in
Teil Nordafrikas und in Nahen Osten so
etwas wie Demokratie und Stabilität
erhofften auf jeden Fall dabei bleiben
wir an diesem Thema dran und es wird
noch so einige Videos über den Iran
geben aber wie immer interessiert uns an
dieser Stelle erstmal eure Meinung
glaubt ihr das Ende des monarchiens sei
gekommen ist vielleicht ein
Regimewechsel in diesem Land ohne einen
Bürgerkrieg möglich oder besteht die
akute Gefahr eines Krieges zwischen Iran
und Saudi-Arabien und könnte Russland
dabei irgendwie den Iran beistehen ich
hoffe dass euch dieses Video gefallen
hat und ihr vielleicht auch etwas dabei
gelernt habt falls ja Freunde und
vergessliches Abo mit Glöckchen und
keines unserer Videos mehr zu verpassen
natürlich freuen wir uns auch jederzeit
über die Spende von euch dieses Projekt
weiterzuführen den Link dazu findet ihr
in der Beschreibung unter diesem Video
macht's gut und bis bald
[Musik]